remember this backstory of when Ivanka
Trump Donald Trump's daughter sat in for
Donald Trump at a meeting during not the
most recent Asia trip but I believe it
was the first Asia trip that Trump did
during his presidency although maybe no
you know what it wasn't his first Asia
trip I think it was during the g20 or
the g8 one of the G meetings I think in
Germany or something like that like that
in any case Trump was apparently so
tired from the trip that Ivanka Trump
showed up and there were a few problems
with it at the time number one she has
no formal position in the administration
number two she can't have a formal
position in the administration since
they have these things called laws
against nepotism and once again Ivanka
Trump is going to be representing an
official American delegation instead of
the actual Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson there's this Global
Entrepreneurship summit in India and
it's put on by the State Department
right this is an official event and in
the past for example under Obama the
Secretary of State in that case it was
John Kerry at the time would attend this
thing this year not only is Rex
Tillerson not even going he's not
representing the US delegation either
but the president's daughter an
unelected Ivanka Trump not someone
confirmed to any position by the Senate
is going to be representing the American
delegation not to mention someone with
endless financial conflicts of interest
that Ivanka Trump holds she's not
qualified by the way to speak on the
subject matter of this summit which is
going to include sort of representing
women in the work world but put that
aside for a second Ivanka trunks only
could've uncle Trump's only credential
and it's really kind of a so-called
credential is that she's the daughter of
the President of the United States and I
want to propose a very simple thought
experiment to you can you imagine for a
second Hillary Clinton were President of
the United States and it were announced
that Chelsea Clinton rather than the
Secretary of State would be representing
the United States
internationally it would be 24/7
coverage on right-wing media endless
period full stop it would be a major
scandal and I don't want to be
hyperbolic here we've been tracking the
authoritarian creep or I guess a better
way to describe it is the creeping
authoritarianism that's been taking
place under Donald Trump for more than
ten months now when you have an
unelected daughter of a world leader
representing the country around the
world that is pushing the us closer to
an authoritarian dictatorship I'm not
saying the United States is a
dictatorship
I'm not saying Donald Trump is going to
successfully turn the u.s. into a
dictatorship I'm not saying anything of
the kind but what I'm saying is when you
look at the spectrum and you consider
what sort of events go more in the
direction of being typical of
authoritarian dictators the having your
family represent the country officially
around the world that's on the list
and that's the point that I'm making it
is one of those hallmarks and why is Rex
Tillerson even tolerating this level of
disrespect I hope and we've heard that
Rex Tillerson has been displeased with
what's going on in the Trump
administration for a while I would love
it if this pushed Rex Tillerson over the
edge and that he resigns resignations
are lovely this time of year it's really
getting cold up in the Northeast and I
would love something to sort of warm the
soul like another Trump cabinet official
resignation by the way we will have news
of another one for you tomorrow Trump's
Ethics lawyer has resigned which is just
lovely
bottom line Ivanka Trump's presence
represents nepotism it represents
corruption it represents greed and
self-aggrandizement and incompetence in
the Oval Office it's actually in a sense
a really good representation of the
Trump administration but it's still
something that we should be really
concerned about and and say it cannot be
tolerated in a democracy in a supposed
democracy like the United States